as more cases of this new variant surge
all across the country here at home
health officials are doing what they can
christian casadas has more on their
efforts kristen well denise the best
protection against the virus according
to health officials is getting
vaccinated and get the booster an urgent
call as we roll into the holidays
should we can be concerned then about a
surge with this virus and i would say
that we should be concerned about a
surge with about sars kobe 2 in the
winter time regardless of omicron local
and state health officials sounding the
alarm today as the u.s now has more
reported cases of the covet variant
omicron mark pandori with the unr public
health lab is urging nevadans to get
vaccinated but it is important to note
that if there's every reason to believe
that vaccines are still going to be a a
good defense against omicron if not
perfect they're going to offer some
degree of protection we've seen this
with other variants ellie graydon with
the nevada health and human services
recommends parents get children five and
older vaccinated too we are lucky with
this particular virus that it does not
cause as a severe disease as frequently
in children
but you know just underscoring we need
to do what we can dwayne young with the
governor's office says the masks will
not come off yet regardless of
vaccination status in counties of higher
substantial transmission we will
continue to have
indoor masking regardless of vaccination
stand a status through the holiday
season and into the start of the new
year
well health officials say you can double
up and get your covid and your flu
vaccine at the same time even after
getting your shot they recommend keeping
the mask on christian casa is live local
now and nevada just one of five states
in the entire country continuing the
indoor mass mandate christian thank you